welcome back to glamour unfiltered
hosted by me josh smith and today we're
joined by
years and years star and now he's
starring in it's a sin it's olly
alexander
it's the sin is amazing i've seen a
couple of episodes of it and it's
heartbreaking the portrayal of the aids
and hiv epidemic in the 80s and it's
such a tricky subject matter and it's
such a heavy subject matter isn't it so
when you first got approached about this
you did the research around it what kind
of shocked you
the most from your discoveries
well oh my gosh so much i mean this is a
period of history that's like
very um there's there's so much that you
could go into
and kind of discover and what i was
really struck by
um how much misinformation and
misunderstanding there was
um when this mysterious illness arrived
in the uk because people just had no
idea
what it was where it came from uh what
it would do
um but something started killing people
you know it's literally a death sentence
this illness and you know when it first
appeared people did the hysteria and the
panic and the fear that it
you know created like you you can't
underestimate it
and it's so different to what was
fascinating to me as well it's so
different to how to now
obviously you know with all the
information we have at our fingertips
and yet the misinformation and kind of
misunderstanding is still
so prevalent and i think that really
made me go oh wow that's
that's interesting um but there was so
so many things about this period of
history that's so shocking you know you
couldn't get you couldn't get a mortgage
if you were gay like people would ask
you you know have you slept another man
you know you might some people ask if
you slept with another if you've had sex
with an animal
they thought that might be an indication
you have this illness you know it's
crazy or
you know in one case um you know a boy
wasn't let out
he got locked up because people didn't
want to go near him or go near this
potential virus and
you know it's crazy it's it's there's a
lot that that's just like and it really
wasn't that long ago you know
also the weird thing is when you watch
it you then think about the covert 19
outbreak
and how you then think about that in the
same context you're like well the
government didn't actually do anything
to help
the aids and hiv victims in that
situation it's so
it almost makes it more tragic when
you're looking at it and watching it
during a pandemic as well do you find
that
i couldn't believe you know we finished
filming before
the pandemic started but i couldn't
believe the parallels that were
you know that are there and
yeah i i think it's it's hugely
heartbreaking to not to think you know
it it took decades
for effective treatment for people
living with hiv
i mean actually decades you know and now
of course like
people living with hiv can have full
healthy normal lives you know and
that's really that's amazing we've come
so so far but it's taken so long to get
there and it's still
a hugely prevalent you know across the
world and
in different communities and i think
yeah
yeah so watching you know that how this
pandemic has unfolded and it's obviously
it's different
and it's affecting people differently
but the world and the world has really
you know found a vaccine within a year
so
it's it's it's i don't know it's a lot
it's just
it was really shocking to me to think
you know that
history in some ways does repeat itself
doesn't it oh my god 100
you were talking earlier about the kind
of everyday homophobia
that infiltrated society at that time
like you know for instance you went to
go get a mortgage
you probably couldn't get one because
you were a gay man for instance living
in this world today what kind of like
negativity or homophobia
you have to face personally in your own
life and what kind of
how you navigate that negativity when it
comes
to you for me i mean
i i definitely struggled at school i was
bullied at school
and uh in part for you know people would
call me gay and
a puff i wasn't out i didn't even know i
was gay but i was very
um i was a bit i was quite feminine and
i would wear like
makeup sometimes to school on like
non-uniform day and so i made myself a
bit of a target
um without really knowing what my
sexuality was or understanding why
you know why i wanted to dress the way i
wanted to dress or whatever
and then when i got older um you know i
would have the occasional
walking down the street no occasional
people calling out like fatty boy or
whatever
and um i remember like i may i would
always be really scared to like kiss
in the street like kiss a guy in front
of like
you know someone in case they were
walking by and because one time i did
and um
i remember like someone like was driving
by and just like screamed out the window
and like threw something
there's like an insidious like you say
everyday homophobia that's so entrenched
within us and within our society like i
i think
it's baked into us from you know the tv
shows we watched from the newspapers we
read the books we read the culture we
live in and
it all kind of adds together to make you
know
homophobia thing that's that's uh
almost invisible i always think you know
a lot of a lot of gay men
or a lot of gay people understand kind
of homophobia because they themselves
have kind of not wanted
you know for me i didn't want to be gay
and i was quite that's my homophobia to
myself you know
i was like almost like this homophobic
gay because i was so
i so hated myself for being like that
and you were kind of like
why is this happening to me and then you
can kind of then almost rationalize why
people
were like that it's such a weird kind of
experience that really happens in that
kind of coming out and
coming up one with yourself process
isn't it that not many people actually
talk about
yeah it's it's really tough i think you
know for me i came out
to myself and to my friends my family my
mum when i was about 19.
but it has taken me you know i'm still
figuring out how to feel
you know comfortable and or truthful or
whatever it is but it but
i think because once you come out it's
like okay well that doesn't undo
all the um the way that you feel about
that word gay or that that actually that
identity you know
it takes years to really like to
to understand what it means and to feel
comfortable within it you know
i would still you know like be
i can't kind of like once the once um
years and years once the band kind of
took off i felt like i was it kind of
was a relief because i felt like people
knew i was gay i didn't have to sort of
announce it to people you know which was
sort of a bit of a relief it was like
i'm already out to everyone now
but you know sometimes like a taxi
driver would like ask me
i remember a taxi driver asking me if i
had a girlfriend and i didn't correct
i was just like no and i didn't correct
him and i was like this is embarrassing
like i'm
actually like a singer in a band that
like i'm i'm very gay like i'm very open
again i'm shocked when people don't
think i'm gay but this taxi driver asked
me this question i was just
i was embarrassed i was like no i don't
have a girlfriend i didn't say anything
and then i
felt really i felt ashamed about that
and then the next time it happened
i like was like no i'm gay and it was
like i felt like a little bit nervous
you know just telling this random dude
that i was getting i was like how stupid
you know it's so silly that i still feel
like this but it's just
you can't get you can't you can't just
get rid of the way
i don't know how do you feel how do you
feel about that stuff i feel like
i had a couple discussions with a lot of
people about this recently actually
i was talking to ariana debose you know
who's in the prom
and was talking to her about it and she
said that she constantly feels like
every single day she's coming out in
some way so she's literally it's a
never-ending process because also
one of the things that's so tricky still
now is there isn't necessarily this like
spectrum grace within the lgbtq plus
community
and everyone needs that's one of the
issues i think there still is because
we're still having to come out to each
other and learning how to respect each
other
underneath this umbrella whilst also
then trying to get society to respect us
in the way that we should be as well i
think that's a whole
other dynamic to it as well do you think
that's quite prevalent too
yeah i think that's a really good point
if i i
i think the commun as a community as a
you know the queer community we
we're a real mix of so many different
identities
so many different communities i mean the
calling it a community is quite it's
it's
it's almost problematic because i feel
that we are one and that
ah you know we uplift each other
that's what i love about being part of
the community and
and and learning about other people's
experiences but i think it's difficult
like you say because it feels like
unstable ground all the time and people
are kind of getting to grips with maybe
one part of an identity but not another
and then they don't want to hear
it and it's like that conflicts with
with my rights and my values but
but i disagree you know i think that it
doesn't there has to be a place where we
can all get to
you know something that's like equality
or better than what we have now and it
doesn't it doesn't conflict with anyone
else's rights right like
i think for the main mainly now is like
i see a lot of
you know hatred and fear and craziness
directed at trans people and i think it
feels like an evolution of homophobia
um it feels very close and and i and i
you know that's that worries me a lot
yeah i think that's what's so scary
about it because
we all just need to come together in
this moment especially when we're
more divided than ever we're sitting in
our homes on our own
mostly or in a bubble or like and we're
so
we're so spread out but there is still
this community out there
you just gotta get out there and find it
and find your people right that's the
most special thing
and i think one of the things that's so
amazing about it's a sin as well is it
actually
really goes into kind of like the mental
health
implications around sexuality in general
but also obviously hiv and aids and
dealing with that
how have you learned to deal with and
manage your own
mental health would you say and have you
learnt to look after it
well i can tell you i have like i have
like
basically a list of things that i do so
it's like some of them
are like really are like big ones like i
take
i take antidepressants still i've taken
them for like 10 years
and it's a i call it an antidepressant i
mean it's an ssri which is a type of
antidepressant um and i find that really
helpful and it's taken me like
years to get the right dose the right
drug but
you know i've seen so many different
doctors but i think i found what works
for me now
and i still like skype my therapist once
a week
so i have like those two those are like
two really big things not saying that
everyone needs
they absolutely don't need those things
but that's
that's what i i use i have a diary like
in a journal so i write down my
feelings a lot um which
i've always done that i've kept one
since i was 13 and it's just
really if that's really helped me and
like all the advice i've gotten
from people is they always say like
it's good to write your thoughts down
you know you know like when you when
you're feeling something like send
someone a letter but don't send it just
write it
yeah you know so that's my notes are
full of stuff like that
yeah yeah exactly talking about the show
like my character richie like he's very
he has a lot of kind of fear and he
doesn't want to acknowledge
that he's kind of struggling and um for
me like i had to learn that lesson a bit
in my life i had to kind of acknowledge
that
i need help and and it's okay to ask for
support and it's okay to lean on your
friends and like
because i'm one of those people that i
like to be happy fun
ollie all the time you know with my
friends
but um when actually just being
able to say you know oh i i feel a bit
upset about this or i need to talk about
this or
you know it's so simple but it took me a
long time to do and it's that and that
really helps
helps me as well because it's almost
like that idea i feel very similar to
that in the sense of
you always want to play up to being this
fun person right and you want to be like
i'm the larger life person i'm always
really cheery but that can also be very
damaging as well can't it yeah i think a
lot of queer people
relate to this because they're used to
kind of being on a mask or
you know appearing some certain way and
like i mean me this is a story i mean
that's
very much like i relate to that myself
because i i do it for a living you know
i get on stage and
you know do this and um i love it i find
a lot
you know i get a lot of strength from
that but it's also um
it can be exhausting it can be like
you're always trying to
play a character you'll never
authentically yourself
you know if you can't and if you don't
get you know if you're always doing that
i think you feel a bit kind of broken
it's exhausting and i think it's also so
important that
we get to this point where someone can
say oh i take antidepressants i go to
therapy and it's just accepted and it's
like that's a really important thing as
well isn't it
yeah totally you're so right and i think
i'm glad you say that because sometimes
i think like
is that okay for me to even just like
keep but of course it's okay but i still
i still have it myself i'm like is it
okay for me to share that i take
antidepressants and i mean
of course i want to and like
i think you're right like we're in a
place now where it's
where where you know people can have a
conversation about a mental health like
this and it's respected and like
that's amazing you know and i think
what's so powerful about it's a sin as
well and you've been talking about this
is
the idea of friendship and there is this
friendship element to it which is so
important and so powerful but if there
was a time in your life
where you could go back and be a friend
to yourself
when would it have been and what would
you say
to that ollie so my younger self i would
probably go
i would go back to myself at primary
school because
i was just very unhappy at primary
school if i'm honest like
my last year primary school i was just
so
miserable i remember being so miserable
and that kind of like carried on to my
first couple years of secondary school
and i would go back and i would just say
you know what ollie
i don't know if he would be able to hear
this so i might just like you know what
i would just be like
let's chill i'm gonna hang out with you
let's watch some cartoons like i'm here
to be your friend
but if i could say something to him and
he would listen i would be like all that
stuff that you think is wrong about
yourself
because you know the ways in which you
think you're faulty or wrong
um just chill because
that's gonna really be good for you in
the end that's gonna what
is gonna be your strength and it's going
to make you special
so try not to get too
down about that stuff like it's gonna it
gets
better yeah um i guess i would do that
do you think you're kind of doing this
and you know when you go out on stage
you're living your best life and you
know you're at glastonbury doing these
incredible things and
you know being an amazing tv show is
like it's sinner you're kind of doing it
for
that person in a way yes exactly yes 100
that's what i was going to say i was
going to be like i'm kind of like i
actually think that sometimes
that i'm kind of like if time travel was
real
like maybe you know like wait this
doesn't make any sense
like because i feel like i'm going back
in time to my younger self and being
like
hey you can do this because because i
have a lot you know if i'm like oh i'm
really scared i can't do this
i'll think about my younger self and go
okay well
you can do it you know i think that all
the time we've all got to be doing it
for our younger selves right
yeah exactly well keep doing it
keep going out there and shining because
we need it so
and congrats it seems amazing but it's
been amazing talking to you ali so
stay safe you too navigate lockdown 3.0
we've got this we got this the speech is
super soon thank you ali
thank you bye okay i'm gonna go
[Music]
bye
you